This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Two thousand years ago, in ancient Greece, a local ruler had a problem. He suspected his new crown was not made of solid gold, but he couldn't prove it. So he asked the kingdom's most famous mathematician Archimedes to investigate. While pondering this puzzle, Archimedes took a bath. He filled it up to the brim and as he stepped in, the water overflowed. Archimedes had a flash of insight. The water that spilled out of the bath reflected the volume of his own body. He realized that if he put the crown into water, he could measure its volume by seeing how much water was displaced. He could use
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。两千年前，在古希腊，一位当地统治者遇到了一个难题。他怀疑自己的新王冠不是纯金做的，但他无法证明。于是他请王国里最著名的数学家阿基米德进行调查。在思考这个难题时，阿基米德去洗了个澡。他把浴缸装满水，当他跨进去时，水溢了出来。阿基米德灵光一现。溢出浴缸的水反映了他自己身体的体积。他意识到，如果把王冠放进水里，他可以通过观察排出的水量来测量它的体积。他可以利用
this to tell the difference between a crown made of pure gold and one that had impurities. He was so excited with his discovery that he leaped out of the tub and ran naked through the streets, shouting, Urika, Urika, which is Greek for, I found it. The famous story of the Urika moment may or may not have happened. It was written 200 years after Archimedes died, but it says something profound about our minds. A good explanation gives us pleasure. And when we can't come up with a good explanation, we feel dissatisfied. Something in the human mind yearns to make sense of the world. Some researchers think this sense-making drive is a basic human impulse, no different than
这一点来区分纯金王冠和掺了杂质的王冠。他对自己发现的这个方法感到非常兴奋，以至于跳出浴缸，赤身裸体地跑上街头，大喊着“尤里卡，尤里卡”，这是希腊语，意思是“我找到了”。关于“尤里卡时刻”的著名故事可能发生过，也可能没有。它是在阿基米德去世200年后才被写下来的，但它对我们的思想有着深刻的启示。一个好的解释能给我们带来快乐。而当我们无法得出一个好的解释时，我们会感到不满。人类思想中总有一种渴望去理解世界的冲动。一些研究人员认为，这种寻求意义的驱动力是一种基本的人类本能，与
thirst or hunger. This week on Hidden Brain, we begin a three-part series about our need to explain the world and how the stories we tell ourselves can lead to discovery, delight and disaster. Why is my friend late? How does nuclear fission work? What exactly is happening when I sneeze? Human beings have an endless number of questions. At Princeton University, psychologist Tanya Lombrozo
口渴或饥饿没有什么不同。本周在《隐藏的大脑》节目中，我们将开始一个三部分的系列节目，探讨我们解释世界的需要，以及我们告诉自己的故事如何导致发现、喜悦和灾难。为什么我的朋友迟到了？核裂变是如何工作的？我打喷嚏时到底发生了什么？人类有无穷无尽的问题。在普林斯顿大学，心理学家坦尼娅·隆布罗佐
is interested in why we come up with all these questions and how our drive to make sense of the world reveals something fundamental about our minds. Tanya Lombrozo, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me. Tanya, I want to start with a personal mystery you once encountered in your own life. Your toddler returned home from preschool one day wearing different pants than the ones she wore in the morning.
对我们为什么会提出所有这些问题，以及我们理解世界的驱动力如何揭示了我们思想的本质感兴趣。坦尼娅·隆布罗佐，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢你的邀请。坦尼娅，我想从你生活中曾经遇到的一个个人谜题开始。有一天，你的幼儿从幼儿园回家时，穿的裤子和你早上送她去时穿的不一样。
Tell me how the rest of this mystery unfolded. So that observation in itself wasn't so surprising. Toddlers have accidents of all kinds all the time. And so it was pretty familiar that you might have different pants because your potty training child might have had an accident. But at this point, my toddler had been very well potty trained for months and hadn't had an accident. And so on Monday, this was a little surprising. But it was even more surprising when we went back to pick her up on Tuesday and found again that she had different pants on and had another accident and then on Wednesday
告诉我这个谜题的后续是如何展开的。所以，那个观察本身并不令人惊讶。幼儿总是会发生各种各样的意外。所以，因为你的孩子正在进行如厕训练，可能会发生意外，所以换了裤子是很常见的。但在这一点上，我的孩子已经进行了几个月的如厕训练，而且没有发生过意外。所以周一的时候，这有点令人惊讶。但更令人惊讶的是，当我们周二去接她时，发现她又换了不同的裤子，又发生了一次意外，然后是周三
and then on Thursday. So I found the teacher and said, what's going on? She was perfectly potty trained. What happened? And the teacher explained that on Monday, she'd made an interesting observation that the girls peed sitting down but the boys peed standing up and she'd thought to herself, I want to learn how to do that too. And so all week she had been practicing peeing standing up. Now this is a really charming story, but I want to draw your attention to Tanya's
然后是周四。所以我找到了老师，问，发生了什么事？她已经完全学会了如厕。发生了什么？老师解释说，周一，她观察到一个有趣的现象：女孩是坐着小便的，而男孩是站着小便的，她心想，我也想学那样做。于是整个星期她都在练习站着小便。现在，这是一个非常迷人的故事，但我想请你注意坦尼娅
thought process as the week unfolded. On Monday, when her child came home wearing different pants, she came up with one explanation. Her daughter had had an accident. But when the same thing happened on Tuesday and Wednesday, Tanya came up with a different explanation. Maybe her daughter was regressing on her party training. Finally, when the teacher explained what was going on, Tanya now had one simple story that unified and explained everything. As a researcher, Tanya is fascinated by how our minds yearn for such stories and explanations and what happens when we can't find them. And one very mundane example that I can think of is the experience I had when I was trying to find parking as a
随着那一周的展开，她的思维过程。周一，当她的孩子穿着不同的裤子回家时，她想出了一个解释。她的女儿发生了意外。但当同样的事情在周二和周三发生时，坦尼娅想出了一个不同的解释。也许她的女儿在如厕训练上退步了。最后，当老师解释了发生了什么时，坦尼娅现在有了一个简单明了的故事，统一并解释了一切。作为一名研究人员，坦尼娅对我们的思想如何渴望这样的故事和解释，以及当我们找不到它们时会发生什么感到着迷。我能想到的一个非常平凡的例子是我在尝试寻找停车位时的经历，当时我作为
professor at Berkeley where I taught for many years and people who live in the area know that parking can be a challenge. And so I would develop all of these pet theories, that maybe if it was, if it was noon on a Tuesday, then this particular parking lot was probably a good place to park, because at noon I bet the law school professors go out to lunch, but the engineers,
伯克利的教授，我在那里教书多年，住在该地区的人都知道停车可能是一个挑战。所以我制定了所有这些个人理论，也许如果是周二中午，那么这个特定的停车场可能是一个停车的好地方，因为我打赌中午法学院的教授们会出去吃午饭，但工程师们，
they probably don't go out to lunch. So I shouldn't try the lot by engineering. And so I would develop these pet theories to try to figure out what was going on. And perhaps a given pet theory would work for a week or two, but then by week three, in no longer worked, and I had to say, maybe there's not much patterns here. Maybe I'm picking up on noise. You cite the evolutionary biologist Stephen J. Gold, who once said that humans were primates who tell stories.
他们可能不会出去吃午饭。所以我应该避开工程学院旁边的停车场。所以我制定了这些个人理论来试图弄清楚发生了什么。也许某个个人理论会奏效一两周，但到了第三周，它就不再奏效了，我不得不说，也许这里没有太多的规律。也许我只是在捕捉噪音。你引用了进化生物学家斯蒂芬·杰伊·古尔德的话，他曾经说过人类是讲故事的灵长类动物。
What's the connection between the world of stories and the world of explanations? I think both stories and explanations are ways that we really try to make sense of or understand the world around us. The way I think about them is they're sort of two ends of a continuum. You know, a good story is when that's full of detail and creates visual images and emotions. A good explanation tends to be a bit more abstract. It might appeal to general features of the world for thinking about science. It might appeal to scientific laws or regularities.
故事的世界和解释的世界之间有什么联系？我认为故事和解释都是我们真正试图理解或领悟周围世界的方式。我思考它们的方式是，它们处于一个连续体的两端。你知道，一个好的故事是充满细节、创造视觉图像和情感的故事。一个好的解释往往更抽象一些。它可能会诉诸于世界的普遍特征，以思考科学。它可能会诉诸于科学定律或规律。
And I think if you look at every day cases of explanation, we do a mix of storytelling and appealing to these more general features of the world. So, for example, if you see a friend arrive late to work and you say, why relate to work? The friend might appeal to some general ideas like there was traffic, but you might also tell you how she woke up five minutes later than she intended to, and then she was rushed, and then she burnt her toast. All of these very concrete details that really help you understand firm her perspective, what her morning was like,
我认为如果你观察日常的解释案例，我们会将讲故事和诉诸于这些更普遍的世界特征结合起来。所以，例如，如果你看到一个朋友上班迟到了，你问，为什么上班迟到了？朋友可能会诉诸一些普遍的想法，比如有交通堵塞，但她也可能会告诉你她比预定时间晚醒了五分钟，然后她很匆忙，然后她烤焦了吐司。所有这些非常具体的细节确实能帮助你从她的角度理解她的早晨是怎样的，
and why she's in the emotional state that she's in, and so on. So I think often we do both of these. We do the storytelling, which is very concrete and particular, and we do the explaining, which is much more about extracting the structure of the world in a way that's generalizable. And when you say extracting the structure of the world in a way that's generalizable,
以及她为什么处于那种情绪状态，等等。所以我认为我们经常两者兼顾。我们进行讲故事，这是非常具体和特殊的，我们也进行解释，这更多是关于以一种可概括的方式提取世界的结构。当你提到以一种可概括的方式提取世界的结构时，
what I'm getting from you is that explanations, and to some extent stories as well, are about constructing models for the world. They allow us to cut through confusion, to distill complexity into simplicity. Yes, I think part of what explanations do is that they relate our observations, which are highly variable, changing from moment to moment, to something more like a simple underlying structure
我从你那里得到的是，解释，在某种程度上也包括故事，是关于构建世界的模型。它们使我们能够穿透混乱，将复杂性提炼为简单性。是的，我认为解释的部分作用是，它们将我们高度多变、时刻变化的观察结果，与某种更像简单底层结构的东西联系起来，
that allows us to predict how things might go in the future, to wait a try to extract order and regularity from what might otherwise seem disorganized and unsettling. The more Tanya thought about it, the more she realized that our capacity for explanations needed to be studied carefully. Our drive for explanation itself needed explanation. It's self-needed explanation. For instance, there are times when this drive can make us curious, help us discover new things.
这使我们能够预测未来事情的发展，试图从原本看起来杂乱无章和令人不安的事物中提取秩序和规律。坦尼娅思考得越多，她就越意识到我们对解释的能力需要仔细研究。我们对解释本身的驱动力也需要解释。它本身就需要解释。例如，有时这种驱动力会让我们好奇，帮助我们发现新事物。
But there are other times when our hunger for a simple story can make us leap to conclusions and become less curious. So an everyday example of this that might be familiar to people is the experience of interviewing someone for a position. When we interview people, often I think even without realizing it, we construct a whole story about the kind of person this is and how they're going to do in the job and how they fit into what we're looking for.
但也有其他时候，我们对简单故事的渴望会让我们仓促下结论，变得不那么好奇。一个人们可能熟悉的日常例子是面试某人的经历。当我们面试别人时，通常我认为即使没有意识到，我们也会构建一个关于这个人是什么样的人、他们将如何胜任工作以及他们如何符合我们要求的故事。
And that's one kind of evidence that we might use for deciding who to hire. But then we also have things like their resume and their letters of reference. And perhaps we tend to over rely on our own story that we construct. And under rely on these other sources of evidence that may or may not fit into our story so nicely. So this is not just saying that explanations are sort of deductions we draw from the world.
这是我们决定聘用谁时可能使用的一种证据。但我们也有简历和推荐信之类的东西。也许我们倾向于过度依赖我们自己构建的故事。而对这些可能与我们的故事不那么吻合的其他证据来源依赖不足。所以这并不是说解释只是我们从世界中得出的推论。
It's really saying that explanations are the way we actually see the world. We actually see the world through the explanations and models we build of the world. One way to think about it is that explanations are the currency in which we understand things. We're presented with all sorts of information, but we need to do something with it.
这实际上是说，解释是我们真正看待世界的方式。我们实际上是通过我们构建的世界的解释和模型来看待世界的。思考它的一种方式是，解释是我们理解事物的货币。我们被呈现出各种各样的信息，但我们需要用它做点什么。
And the way we do something with it is to construct some sort of a model, an explanatory model, one that we find explanatory satisfying. And that's what we use as a basis for thinking and reasoning. Well, we'll talk soon about the experiments that you've conducted to analyze our capacity for explanation, but I want to start with a story that illustrates so much about our drive for explanation. You once drew a link between your daughter's personality and what you
而我们用它做点什么的方式是构建某种模型，一种解释性模型，一种我们认为具有解释力且令人满意的模型。这就是我们作为思考和推理基础的东西。好吧，我们很快会谈谈你为分析我们的解释能力而进行的实验，但我先从一个故事开始，它说明了我们对解释的驱动力。你曾经在你女儿的个性和你
knew about her before she was born. Can you explain, Tanya? Sure. So, when I was pregnant with my first daughter, I discovered around seven months into the pregnancy that she was breached. For those of you who haven't gone through this process and are familiar with it, that just basically means her head was up rather than down, and that's not you want it to be before birth. And so being a good scientist I did all sorts of research on how she might be able to turn around and the probability that she would turn around before birth and so on, but in fact she was very comfortable in just the position she was and did not turn around prior to birth. This daughter is now 10 and we still joke that this illustrates her wonderful persistence
在她出生前对她的了解之间建立了一种联系。你能解释一下吗，坦尼娅？当然。所以，当我怀上第一个女儿时，我在怀孕七个月左右时发现她是臀位。对于那些没有经历过这个过程且不熟悉它的人来说，这基本上意味着她的头朝上而不是朝下，这不是你希望在出生前出现的情况。所以作为一个好科学家，我做了各种关于她如何能够转过来，以及她在出生前转过来的概率等等的研究，但事实上她在那个位置非常舒服，并没有在出生前转过来。这个女儿现在10岁了，我们仍然开玩笑说这说明了她极好的坚持
and stubbornness. You know, she's very steadfast in the best way that I think will make her an amazing adult and sometimes a frustrating child. You know, of course, on some level, I don't really think there is a connection between her having been in a breach position before she was born and her being a persistent, stubborn child later. But it's so tempting to draw these connections and to see these patterns and to try to make sense of what we observe now in terms of what we know about the past. And what I love about this is it shows how in discriminant
和固执。你知道，她以最好的方式非常坚定，我认为这会让她成为一个了不起的成年人，有时也是一个令人沮丧的孩子。你知道，当然，在某种程度上，我并不真的认为她出生前处于臀位和她后来成为一个坚持、固执的孩子之间有什么联系。但试图建立这些联系，看到这些模式，并试图根据我们对过去的了解来理解我们现在观察到的东西，是如此诱人。我喜欢这一点的是，它展示了我们在为那些原本感觉无法解释的事情寻找解释时是多么不加区分。
we are in coming up with explanations for things that otherwise feel inexplicable. I think that's right. I think very often the world presents us with ambiguity. And what we do is we try to connect the dots in a way that tells a compelling narrative and that allows us to have a sense that there is order. When we come back, we look at the great benefits and the great dangers that are contained in our
我认为那是对的。我认为世界经常给我们带来模糊性。而我们所做的是试图以一种讲述引人入胜的叙事的方式连接这些点，这使我们有一种秩序感。当我们回来时，我们将看看我们解释世界的驱动力中包含的巨大好处和巨大危险。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。当你还是个孩子的时候，你可能一直都在问一个非常重要的问题。为什么？为什么会有云？为什么水会沸腾？为什么我需要？如果你是一个成年人，你可能仍然会问为什么，即使其他问题可能不同。为什么我的同事迟到了？
drive to explain the world. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. When you were a kid, you probably asked a very important question all the time. Why? Why are there clouds? Why does water boil? Why do I need? If you're a grown-up, you might still ask why even other questions might be different. Why is my colleague late?
为什么我的狗看起来很悲伤？为什么我的邻居比我更成功？在普林斯顿大学，心理学家坦尼娅·隆布罗佐研究我们理解正在发生的事情、解释世界的强大驱动力，以及我们对解释的追求能揭示关于我们的什么。坦尼娅，你的父亲受过电气工程师的培训，在去日本出差期间，他有时会带回一些神秘的小电子礼物给你玩。告诉我你用它们做了什么，以及你作为一名科学家，在你童年经历和你今天的研究之间建立的联系。
Why does my dog seem sad? Why is my neighbor more successful than I am? At Princeton University, psychologists Tanya Lombroso studies are powerful drive to understand what is happening, to explain the world and what our search for explanations can reveal about us. Tanya, your father was trained as an electrical engineer, and during business trips to Japan, he would sometimes bring back mysterious little electronic gifts for you to play with. Tell me what you did with them, and the connection that you have made between that childhood
好吧，我父亲带回这些神秘礼物时有一个规则，那就是如果我和我哥哥能弄清楚它们是如何工作的，我们就可以保留它们。这是一个挑战，因为一切都是日语。而且它们通常非常陌生。我记得有一次他带回了一些东西，我们最终发现是一个闹钟，但它的一侧有一系列数字，另一侧有数字，每个数字都有很多小开关。
experience and your research today as a scientist. Well, my father had a rule when he came back with these mysterious gifts, which was that if my brother and I could figure out how they worked, we could keep them. And this was a challenge because everything was in Japanese. And often they were very unfamiliar. I remember one time he brought back something which we eventually discovered was an alarm clock, but it had a series of numbers of rate on one side and numbers on the other side and lots of little switches for each of the numbers.
所以通过正确的数字组合，你可以指定你想要它在什么时间响。所以我们必须做的是基本上观察这些人工制品的特征，试图弄清楚它们不同的按钮是做什么的，思考为什么有人会以那种特定的方式设计它，对吧？考虑到它是以这种特定的方式设计的，它可能是为了什么？而那种逆向工程的过程，观察某物的行为，它
And so with the right combination of numbers, you could sort of specify what time you wanted it to sound. And so what we had to do was basically look at the features of these artifacts, try to figure out what different buttons they did, think about why someone might have designed it in that particular way, right? What might it be for, given that it was designed in this particular way? And that sort of process of reverse engineering, of looking at some things behavior, what it
看起来像什么，它如何表现，然后试图向后思考它的功能必须是什么，这样你就可以理解为什么它具有这些属性，这非常像心理学家所做的事情，观察人类行为，然后试图弄清楚为什么大脑以那种方式工作。坦尼娅不仅对别人的大脑这样做。她也对自己这样做。例如，她想在半夜醒来，因为她听到了一些神秘的声音。
looks like, how it behaves, and then trying to think backwards to what its function must be, such that you can understand why it has those properties, that's very much what a psychologist does, looking at human behavior, and then trying to figure out why the mind works the way it does. Tanya doesn't just do this with other people's minds. She does it with her own. For example, she wants to walk up in the middle of the night because she heard some mysterious sounds.
当然，她做了我们任何人在那种情况下都会做的事情。她寻找解释。所以这是在我女儿大概三岁左右的时候，我母亲来访，当我听到噪音时，我走到卧室门外，发现我母亲和女儿坐在黑暗中，桌子周围放着毛绒玩具，假装吃蛋糕等等。所以我非常困惑。我也知道我母亲更喜欢在凌晨3点睡觉。
Of course, she did what any of us would do in that situation. She looked for an explanation. So this was when my daughter was probably around three, and my mother was visiting, and when I heard noise, I went outside of my bedroom door, and I found my mother and my daughter sitting in the dark having a full-blown tea party with stuffed animals around the table and pretend to cake, and so on. So I was very puzzled. I also know that my mother would prefer to be sleeping at 3 a.m.
那么这是怎么发生的呢？这似乎是一件需要解释的事情。你发现了什么？背后是什么？我发现的是，我女儿醒了，非常兴奋她的祖母在访。所以直接下楼去叫醒我母亲。当我母亲被叫醒时，她并不觉得天黑很奇怪，因为我女儿经常在太阳升起前醒来。所以，她只是以为是早晨。
So how had this happened? This seemed to something that called out for explanation. And what did you find out? What was behind it? What I discovered was that my daughter had woken up and was very enthusiastic that her grandmother was visiting. So went straight downstairs to wake up my mother. And when my mother was woken up, she didn't think it was strange that it was dark because my daughter often woke up before the sun came up. So, she just thought it was morning.
现在，你可以在这一点上说，这是不可接受的。现在是凌晨三点。回去睡觉，把他们两个都送回床上，然后回去睡觉。但在某些方面，这对你来说是不够的。你实际上想知道他们为什么在那里，找出发生了什么对于知道你所看到的事情的正确反应实际上非常重要。绝对。我认为这对于能够预测它何时会再次发生，能够更多地实现它或防止它，取决于它是一个我们想要的结果还是我们倾向于避免的结果，也非常重要。
Now, you could just say at this point, this is unacceptable. It's three o'clock in the morning. Go back to bed, send them both back to bed and go back to sleep. But in some ways, that was inadequate for you. You actually wanted to know why they were there, it was important for you to find out, explaining what happened is actually really important to knowing what the correct responses to the thing that you're seeing. Absolutely. I think it's also very important to being able to anticipate when it will happen again, to being able to bring it about more or to prevent it, depending on whether it's an outcome that we want or prefer to avoid.
所以我认为我们从一个事件的解释中得到了很多，特别是当它涉及人和关于责任和指责的担忧时，那么确切地知道某人为什么那样做是非常重要的。我们之前谈到了解释在产生一个更可预测的世界方面为我们提供的价值。你能多谈谈这个想法吗？我正在思考体育世界。双方球员进攻和防守的良好结合。你知道，如果你理解对手正在使用的策略，而不仅仅是对对手当下所做的任何事情做出反应，竞争就会变得容易得多，
So I think there's a lot we get out of an explanation for an event, especially when it involves people and concerns about responsibility and blame, then knowing exactly why someone acted the way they did is incredibly important. We talked earlier about the value that explanations provide us in terms of producing a world that is more predictable. Can you talk about this idea a little more? I'm thinking about the world of sports. Good combination of attacking and defending from the both guys. You know, if you understand the strategy and opponent is using not just sort of responding to whatever your opponent is doing in the moment, it becomes much easier to compete and
也更容易获胜。这是一个很好的例子。我承认我不了解体育世界。所以我相信你的话，但这说得通。但我认为通常情况是这样的。我的意思是，如果你考虑试图预测某人的行为，对吧？也许你有一个死对头，你正试图预测他们的下一步行动。如果你理解是什么在激励他们，为什么他们表现得那样？
much easier to win. That's a great example. I will confess I do not understand the world of sports. So I will take your word for it, but that makes sense. But I think it's generally the case. I mean, if you think about trying to anticipate somebody's behavior, right? Perhaps you have an arch nemesis and you're trying to anticipate their next move. If you understand what's motivating them, why are they acting the way they are?
他们的目标是什么？如果你有这些问题的答案，你将处于更好的位置来预测他们要做什么，并有可能防止它。哦，哇！拖鞋不是！好吧，我非常，我没想到他当时会到那里。当我阅读你的作品时，我意识到，你知道，我们不仅从我们发现的解释中受益，
What's their goal? If you have answers to those questions, you'll be in a much better position to anticipate what they're going to do and potentially to prevent it. Oh, wow! Slipper is not! Well, I was extremely, one I didn't think he was going to get there then. And as I was reading your work, I was realizing that, you know, we don't just benefit from the explanations that we discover,
我们还从许多在我们之前的人类的解释中受益。我的意思是，你甚至可以说文化是一种将解释从一代传给下一代的机制。绝对。我认为，通常当我们考虑从解释中学习时，我们想到的是从我们从其他人或书中收到的解释中学习。我认为这也许不太被认可，但同样重要的是，我们也通过尝试自己获得解释来学习。
we benefit from the explanations of many human beings who came before us. I mean, you might even argue that culture is a mechanism to transmit explanations from one generation to the next. Absolutely. I think, typically, when we think about learning from explanations, what we have in mind is learning from the explanations that we receive from other people or from books. I think it's perhaps less recognized, but equally important, that we also learn by trying to get explanations ourselves.
有时这会激励我们获得证据并进行新的观察，但有时我们仅仅通过尝试向自己解释就能学到新东西。有一种现象叫做自我解释效应，我认为大多数人可能都经历过，那就是通过尝试向自己或别人解释而更好地理解某事。这种现象中神秘和令人惊奇的部分是，这是一种发生的学习，即使你没有从别人或外部世界获得新信息，你只是在重新排列和审视已经在你脑海中的东西。
Sometimes that motivates us to get evidence and make new observations, but sometimes we can learn something new just by trying to explain to ourselves. There's a phenomenon called the self-explanation effect that I think most people have probably experienced, and that's the experience of coming to understand something better as a result of trying to explain it to yourself or to somebody else. Part of what's sort of mysterious and amazing about the phenomenon is that that's a kind of learning that occurs, even though you're not getting new information from anybody else or from the external world, you're just rearranging and scrutinizing what's already in your head.
而在做这件事的过程中，你有时会经历这些顿悟时刻，并意识到你更好地理解了某事，或者意识到你更好地理解了某事。或者有时意识到你以为你理解了某事，但实际上你的知识中有一个重要的空白需要填补。造成这种情况的原因之一是所谓的解释深度错觉。你刚才提到了这一点。你能拆解一下那个想法吗，托尼？是的，绝对。
And in the course of doing that, you can sometimes have one of these aha moments and come to realize that you understand something better, or and come to realize that you understand something better. Or sometimes come to realize that you thought you understood something, but that there's actually an important gap in your knowledge that you need to fill. One of the reasons for this is something called the illusion of explanatory depth. Then you hinted at this just a second ago. Can you unpack what that idea is, Tony? Yeah, absolutely.
我们许多人觉得我们了解我们日常生活中许多设备是如何工作的。我们了解自行车是如何工作的。我们了解微波炉是如何工作的，拉链是如何工作的，等等。如果你问人们，他们通常会说，是的，我了解拉链是如何工作的。然后你说，好吧，你能解释一下吗？
Many of us feel like we understand how a lot of the devices in our everyday life work. We understand how a bicycle works. We understand how a microwave works, how a zipper works, and so on. If you ask people, they'll typically say, yeah, I understand how a zipper works. And then you say, okay, can you please explain it?
当人们真正尝试解释像拉链是如何工作的东西时，发生的事情是他们开始意识到他们可能真的没有关于拉链是如何工作的完整故事的所有方式。而尝试生成一个好的解释的过程帮助我们意识到我们真的做得不够。我见过一些实验，你要求人们画一辆自行车，例如，人们会画一个连接自行车两个轮子的链条，这当然会使自行车实际上不可能骑行。你很快意识到，即使是极其基本的事情，我们可能实际上并不太了解它们是如何工作的，但它实际上需要我们被置于
And what happens when people actually try to explain something like how a zipper works, is they start to appreciate all of the ways in which maybe they really don't have the full story of how a zipper works. And the process of trying to generate a good explanation helps us appreciate that we're really falling short. I've seen experiments where you ask people to draw a bicycle, for example, and people will draw a chain that connects the two wheels of the bicycle together, which of course would make the bicycle impossible to actually ride. And you realize very quickly that even when it comes to extremely basic things, we might actually not understand very well how they work, but it actually requires us to be put
现场才能揭示我们知识中的这个空白。那是对的。心理学家有时会谈论所谓的元认知，也就是关于我们自己认知的认知。在这种情况下，我们的元认知往往是错误的。我们经常认为我们知道一些我们实际上不知道的事情。而在尝试解释它的过程中，我们可以更好地校准并欣赏我们所知道的
on the spot to be able to reveal this gap in our knowledge. That's right. Psychologists sometimes talk about what's called metacognition, which is sort of our cognition about our own cognition. And this is the case where our metacognition is often wrong. We often think we know something that we actually don't know. And in the process of trying to explain it, we can get better calibrated and appreciate what we do
和我们不知道的。我认为这就是尝试解释可以非常强大的原因之一。但我认为在其他情况下，它实际上也可以帮助你不仅识别空白，甚至填补它们。坦尼娅引用了PBS电视剧《比彻姆大宅》中的场景。它设定在18世纪末的印度。一个英国人被指控从皇帝那里偷窃，
and we don't know. I think that's one of the reasons trying to explain can be really powerful. But I think in other cases, it can also actually help you not just recognize gaps, but even fill them. Tanya Cites is seen from the PBS TV series Beechham House. It's set in India in the late 18th century. An Englishman has been accused of having stolen
他被关进了监狱牢房。所以他在他的牢房里，试图向自己解释这是怎么发生的，他在想，你知道，谁可能背叛了我？他们为什么要背叛我？皇帝怎么可能知道被盗财产在哪里以及在我家里等等？
from the Emperor, and he's put in a jail cell. And so he's in his jail cell, trying to explain to himself how this happened, and he's thinking to himself, you know, who could have betrayed me? Why would they have betrayed me? How could the Emperor have known where the stolen property was and in my house and so on?
而从那个牢房里，他没有得到任何新信息。他没有任何新的证据，然而仅仅通过思考，并思考他已经拥有的所有证据片段，就让他有了顿悟时刻，意识到是谁背叛了他。有了这个新的洞察力，英国人面对了犯罪的真正肇事者。你知道有无数的候选人。我得出了一个简单的问题。谁获益最多？
And from that jail cell, he doesn't get any new information. He doesn't have any new piece of evidence, and yet just thinking it through, and thinking about all of the pieces of evidence he already had allows him to have the aham moment where he realizes who has betrayed him. With this new insight, the Englishman confronts the true perpetrator of the crime. You know there are innumerable candidates. I have arrived at one simple question. Who had the most to gain?
我得出了一个简单的问题，谁获益最多。我现在意识到你不是偶然遇到我母亲的。你是蓄意为之。你确切地知道她要去哪里以及她什么时候会离开。你可能已经监视她好几个月了。所以，有时我们通过获得新证据或询问其他人来学习，但有时我们仅仅通过以正确的方式思考事物来学习。这是一个我称之为通过思考来学习的过程，
I have arrived at one simple question who had the most to game. I realize now you did not meet my mother by chance of the doxie cow-cotta. You were there by design. You knew exactly where she was going and when she would leave. You'd probably be monitoring her for months. So, sometimes we learn by getting new evidence or by asking other people, but sometimes we learn just by thinking about things in the right way. It's a process I refer to as learning by thinking,
在这种情况下，通过尝试向自己解释来学习。你知道，前段时间在《隐藏的大脑》中，我们与研究员维拉·托宾交谈过。她研究讲故事的人利用我们认知系统的技术，她说了一些非常接近你刚才告诉我的话。我想播放一小段她说的话。故事能为你做的是构建这种洞察体验，让你感觉不是有什么东西让你措手不及，或者你只是被惊喜所困，而是这种体验，
in this case, learning by trying to explain to yourself. You know, sometime ago on Hidden Brain, we spoke with the researcher Vera Tobin. She studies the techniques that storytellers use to take advantage of our cognitive systems, and she said something that is very close to what you just told me a second ago. I want to play a short clip of what she said. What a story can do for you is construct this insight experience where you feel not that something has blindsided you or that you were just taken by surprise, but this experience that
感觉就像你对事物如何组合在一起有了真正的顿悟时刻，这是人类非常喜欢的东西。所以当我听到维拉说那句话时，坦尼娅，有两件事让我跳出来，讲故事的人正在做两件事。第一，他们实际上正在构建一个内置了神秘、困惑和不确定性的故事。因为我们发现这些东西是令人厌恶的，它实际上充当了一个钩子，让我们保持倾听，保持观看，保持阅读。然后当提供解释时，它为我们提供了这种快乐的爆发，因为我们突然理解了谜团被解开了，难题被解决了。是的，我喜欢那个例子。而且我还要补充一点，科学通常也可以具有那种特征。
feels as if you have a real aha moment about how things fit together and that is something that humans like a lot. So the two things that's jump out at me when I hear Vera say that Tanya is that storytellers are doing two things. One, they're actually constructing a story that has mystery and confusion and uncertainty built into it. And because we find those things aversive, it actually serves as a hook that keeps us listening, keeps us watching, keeps us reading. And then when the explanation is provided, it provides us with this burst of pleasure because we suddenly understand that the mystery is resolved, the puzzle is solved. Yes, I love that example. And I would also add that science can often have that character as well.
所以在好故事的情况下，有一个作者在精心制作故事以具有恰到好处的形式。但我认为科学之所以非常令人满意，部分原因在于有时我们也得到了那种体验，拥有所有这些线索，然后得到令人满意的理论，使所有这些线索以一种有意义的方式组合在一起。我想谈谈解释感觉不令人愉快的时刻。我们都经历过观看魔术并感到惊讶，然后发现魔术背后的解释，而这总是不会产生惊奇，而是产生失望。
So in the case of a good story, there's an author crafting the story to have just the right form. But I think part of what makes science very satisfying is that some of the time we get that experience as well, of having all of these clues and then getting the satisfying theory that makes all of those clues fit together in a way that makes sense. I want to talk a moment about situations where explanations do not feel pleasurable. We've all had the experience of watching a magic trick and being amazed, and then discovering the explanation behind the trick, and invariably this does not produce wonder, but it produces disappointment.
事实上，看起来奇妙的东西结果却是平庸的。你认为这揭示了大脑中的解释系统关于什么的？我认为它告诉我们的一件事是，可能存在我们实际上发现不确定性、神秘和敬畏在某种程度上令人愉快的情况。我认为如果你思考像敬畏这样的情绪，它可能有一种负面的
Something that, in fact, appeared wondrous turns out to be pedestrian. What do you think this reveals about the explanatory system in the brain? One thing that I think it tells us is that there might be cases where we actually find uncertainty and mystery and awe, somewhat pleasurable. I think if you think about an emotion like awe, it has possibly a kind of negative
色彩，对吧？有不确定性而不理解某事可能会有点可怕，但也有它可能令人愉快的方式。它告诉我们这里有东西要学。这是值得注意的东西。所以当我们有某种似乎违背物理定律或概率定律的东西，而结果它只是完全平凡的东西时。我认为在我们的感觉之间存在一种违背，即有什么真正令人惊奇的东西要学习或发现。然后现实是实际上它只是照常营业。所以我们发现的一件事是，人们对科学问题的答案比对宗教问题更感兴趣。
tinge, right? It can be kind of scary to have uncertainty and not understand something, but there's also a way in which it can be pleasurable. It tells us there's something to learn here. Here's something that's worth paying attention to. So when we have something that seems to defy the laws of physics or the laws of probability, and it turns out it was just something completely mundane. I think there's a violation between our sense that there was something really amazing to be learned or discovered. And then the reality that actually it was just business as usual. So one thing that we find is that people are more curious about the answers to questions about science
他们认为我们应该回答科学问题，而不是回答宗教问题。如果我问你，为什么锈是红色的？我说，这是一个谜。这似乎是错的。但如果我说，为什么上帝存在？这是一个谜。为什么耶稣在水上行走？这是一个谜。对于很多关于宗教的问题，不仅仅是我们不知道。而是我们似乎对我们不能知道，也许我们不应该知道的想法感到舒服得多。你认为是什么造成了差异？
than about religion. They think that we should answer science questions more than we should answer questions about religion. If I ask you, why is Russ red? And I say, it's a mystery. That just seems wrong. But if I say, why does God exist? It's a mystery. Why did Jesus walk on water? It's a mystery. For a lot of questions about religion, it's not just that we don't know. It's that we seem to be much more comfortable with the idea that we can't know, and perhaps that we shouldn't know. And what do you think spells the difference?
为什么对于某些事情我们实际上认为你告诉我没有答案是不可接受的？而对于其他事情，我觉得你告诉我有一个答案是不可接受的？我认为有几个因素在起作用。我认为其中之一是我们的信仰为我们扮演各种各样的角色。我们拥有我们所拥有的信仰并渴望拥有特定类型的信仰的一个原因是，因为我们想要准确并以一种将给我们一个模型的方式代表世界，使我们能够预测将会发生什么。但我们的信仰也扮演重要的社会角色。
Why is it that for some things we actually think that it's unacceptable that you tell me that there's no answer to this? And for other things, I feel like it's unacceptable that you tell me that there is an answer to it. I think there's a few factors in play. I think one of them is that our beliefs play all sorts of different kinds of roles for us. One reason that we have the beliefs that we do and that we aspire to have particular kinds of beliefs is because we want to be accurate and represent the world in a way that will give us a model that allows us to predict what will happen. But our beliefs also play important social roles.
它们扮演重要的道德角色。它们扮演重要的道德角色。它们扮演重要的个人角色。而且我认为有时在像宗教或与特定人或机构的关系这样的情况下，要求解释可能会与与关系和信任相关的其他目标竞争。我们也有证据表明，在某些情况下，人们对科学可能完全解释人类大脑的想法感到不舒服。
They play important moral roles. They play important moral roles. They play important personal roles. And I think sometimes in a case like religion or relationships to particular people or institutions, demanding an explanation might compete with other kinds of goals related to relationships and trust. We also have evidence that there are some cases where people are uncomfortable with the idea that science
例如，人们似乎总体上非常乐意认为科学可以解释为什么我们忘记事情，或者立体视觉是如何工作的，或者运动控制是如何工作的，但他们对科学可以解释我们的宗教信仰或我们的道德行为、精神体验或对艺术的欣赏的想法感到不舒服得多。所以所有这些现象都是我们有丰富内在体验的现象，我们觉得作为正在体验它们的人，我们有特殊的访问权限。
could fully explain the human mind. So for example, people seem to, in general, be very comfortable thinking that science could explain why we forget things or how stereo vision works or how motor control works, but they're much less comfortable with the idea that science could explain our religious beliefs or our moral behavior spiritual experience, or appreciation for art. So all of these phenomena are a phenomena that we have a rich internal experience that we feel like we have special access to as the person who's experiencing them.
对于这些现象，人们似乎也认为可能存在一种对那种想法的威胁，即我们大脑之外没有那些丰富个人体验的人可以提供完整的解释。我想知道，告诉我你对这个假设有什么看法，即当我们试图解释事物时，我们正在做的一部分是试图使外部世界对内部世界变得可理解。但内部世界中已经有对我们感觉可理解的东西，对于那些东西，来自外部的解释
And for those phenomena, it also seems like people think there might be a sort of threat to the idea that somebody outside of our own mind who isn't having those rich personal experiences could provide a full explanation. I'm wondering, tell me what you think of this hypothesis that part of what we're doing when we're trying to explain things is we're trying to make the outside world comprehensible to the inside world. But there are things in the inside world that already feel comprehensible to us and for those things, an explanation from the outside does
感觉不受欢迎，但它实际上感觉像是一种入侵。我认为这是一个非常有趣的想法。作为一名心理学家，当然，我想抵制这一点，因为我的工作正是解释内部世界。但我认为你所描述的捕捉到了许多人的体验。有时人们谈论我们是像笛卡尔那样的直觉二元论者的想法。我们认为大脑在某种程度上从根本上与身体分离。
not feel welcome, but it actually feels like an intrusion. I think that's a really interesting idea. As a psychologist, of course, I want to resist that because my job is precisely explaining the internal world. But I think what you describe is capturing something of many people's experience. Sometimes people talk about the idea that we are intuitive dualists like Descartes. We think of the mind as somehow fundamentally separate
所以，我认为在其中一些情况下发生的事情的一部分是，通过试图给我们的内在体验一个外部或科学的解释，我们正在以一种不舒服的方式跨越这些层面。我们正在试图通过诉诸生物或物理的方面来解释心理的方面。当我们回来时，我们的解释驱动力
from the body. And so part of what's going on in some of these cases, I think, is that by trying to give an external or scientific explanation to our internal experience, we are crossing those levels in an uncomfortable way. We're trying to explain aspects of the mental by appeal to aspects of the biological or the physical. When we come back, how our drive for explanations
有时会导致灾难。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。人类似乎拥有一种为事物寻找解释的内在驱动力。这种驱动力使我们好奇，帮助我们发现事物。但尽管我们的解释能力令人印象深刻且有用，心理学家坦尼娅·隆布罗佐也发现，这种驱动力在重要方面可能导致我们误入歧途。坦尼娅，几年前，威斯康星大学的研究人员让孩子们听了一个儿童故事。
can sometimes lead to disaster. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantan. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantan. Human beings seem to possess an innate drive to come up with explanations for things. This drive makes us curious, helps us discover things. But as much as our capacity for explanation is impressive and useful, psychologist Tanya Lombroso has also found there are important ways in which this drive can lead us astray. Tania some years ago, researchers from the University of Wisconsin had kids listen to a children's story.
它来自《大红狗克利福德》系列。有一天，克利福德和他的朋友们发现了一只想要和他们一起玩的新狗，但这只狗在重要方面与他们不同。我想给你播放一小段故事的电视版本。真是个好家伙。他只有三条腿，克利福德。天哪。我们该怎么办，克利福德？他想和我们一起玩。
It was from the series Clifford, the big red dog. One day Clifford and his friends discovered a new dog who wants to play with them, but this dog is different from them in an important way. I want to play you a short clip from the television version of the story. What a nice guy. He's only got three legs, Clifford. Oh my gosh. What should we do, Clifford? He wants to play with us.
它出自《大红狗克里弗》系列。有一天，克里弗和他的朋友们发现了一只想要和他们一起玩的新狗，但这只狗在某个重要方面与他们不同。我想给你们播放一段电视版故事的短片。真是个好家伙。他只有三条腿，克里弗。天哪。我们该怎么办，克里弗？他想和我们一起玩。
So, let's play. I don't know. We just have to read it. So, Tony, what did the research study ask and what did it find? In this study, people were interested in children's ability to extract the moral or the lesson of the story. And as you can probably imagine, in this case with Clifford and the Three-Legged Dog, part of what the story was going for was a general lesson about accepting others who might be different from ourselves about inclusion and so on. But in fact, overwhelmingly, when children were asked about the lesson, they drew a blank or they drew a much, much more specific lesson or moral, like you should be nice to three-legged dogs.
好吧，我们来玩个游戏。我不知道。我们只需要读一下。那么，托尼，这项研究提出了什么问题，又发现了什么？在这项研究中，人们对儿童提取故事寓意或教训的能力很感兴趣。正如你可能想象的那样，在这个关于克利福德和三条腿狗的故事中，故事的部分意图是传达一个关于接纳与我们不同的人、关于包容等等的普遍道理。但事实上，绝大多数孩子在被问及故事的教训时，要么答不上来，要么得出了一个非常、非常具体的教训或道德，比如你应该对三条腿的狗好一点。
Which is not a completely unreasonable conclusion to draw. Absolutely not. I think it makes it makes a normous sense. But of course, if that's the lesson you draw from it, you might wonder about the value of reading a soft fables and other lessons to our children, right? If all they're learning about is how you should act towards tortoises and hairs, a lot of what we want is for them to extract some more general lesson. To put this another way, you can have different levels of explanations. Sometimes your explanation might be correct in a literal sense, but you miss the larger meaning.
这并不是一个完全不合理的结论。绝对不是。我认为这非常有道理。但当然，如果这就是你从中得出的教训，你可能会怀疑给孩子们读《伊索寓言》和其他教训故事的价值，对吧？如果他们学到的只是你应该如何对待乌龟和兔子，那么我们希望他们提取出一些更普遍的教训。换句话说，你可以有不同层面的解释。有时你的解释在字面上可能是正确的，但你却忽略了更深层的含义。
Other times, we may focus too much on the big picture. Think about what happens when the fire alarm goes off in your office. Instead of drawing the simple explanation that something is wrong and you should evacuate the building, you might sit around and wait for a bigger explanation. Is this a real emergency? A drill? I think we often face a trade-off between gathering all of the information and learning as much as possible versus acting in a way that's efficient. And we have to decide when we're gonna decide
其他时候，我们可能过于关注大局。想想当办公室火警响起时会发生什么。你可能不会得出“出事了，应该撤离大楼”这种简单的解释，而是坐在那里等待一个更宏大的解释。这是真正的紧急情况吗？还是演习？我认为我们经常面临在收集所有信息、尽可能多地了解情况与高效行动之间进行权衡。我们必须决定什么时候该下定决心
that we have enough information and just act. In the case that you just described, there are a couple of different types of errors that you could make. And those errors have very different kinds of costs, right? So one kind of error that you could make is failing to learn something that might have been valuable, like whether or not the fire alarm was caused
认为我们已经掌握了足够的信息并采取行动。在你刚才描述的情况下，你可能会犯几种不同类型的错误。而这些错误的代价是非常不同的，对吧？所以你可能犯的一种错误是未能学到一些可能有价值的东西，比如火警是否是由
by microwave popcorn being left too long or by something else. But another kind of error that you might make is spending too much time trying to figure out what happened in not leaving the building, and that is a very costly error. So in that kind of case, it seems like you'd probably be making a mistake to err on the side of trying to learn extra rather than act safely or cautiously. But there's going to be other cases where the cost of failing to learn is the cost that you might want to try to avoid.
微波炉爆米花加热时间过长引起的，还是由其他原因引起的。但你可能犯的另一种错误是花费太多时间试图弄清楚发生了什么，而没有离开大楼，那是一个代价非常高昂的错误。所以在那种情况下，如果你倾向于试图学习更多而不是安全或谨慎地行动，那可能就犯了错误。但也会有其他情况，未能学习的代价正是你可能想要避免的代价。
You also found in other studies that people dislike explanations that are generally very good but that have certain exceptions to the rule. It seems like one thing that we like in an explanation is that it be broad and exceptionless. And so one thing that might happen is that if you have an explanation that only accounts for why your friend acts the way they do on Monday, Tuesday, and Thursday, but not on Wednesday, you're going to think I'm missing something, right? That can't be the whole story. There's something unsatisfying about that and you're going to keep looking until you find
你在其他研究中也发现，人们不喜欢那些通常很好但有某些例外情况的解释。似乎我们喜欢的一种解释是它必须广泛且没有例外。所以可能发生的一件事是，如果你有一个解释只能说明为什么你的朋友在周一、周二和周四表现得那样，但在周三却不是，你会认为我漏掉了什么，对吧？那不可能是全部事实。这其中有些令人不满的地方，你会一直寻找，直到找到
something that accounts for more of your evidence. But I'm also thinking about how this could actually affect us adversely, which is that the real world, in fact, is a messy place. And there are times when a very good rule might actually explain 80% of a phenomenon, that could be an excellent rule.
一些能解释更多证据的东西。但我也在思考这实际上会如何对我们产生不利影响，那就是现实世界实际上是一个混乱的地方。有时一个非常好的规则实际上可能解释了80%的现象，那可能是一个极好的规则。
But the fact that it has 20% of exceptions to that rule, if we start to rule those out as good explanations, we might rule out things that could actually be very useful. That's right. So one danger of trying to look for a good explanation is that the world is not always well-behaved as you point out. Sometimes the world doesn't provide a good explanation. Sometimes things just are coincidences or are chance or don't have elegant explanations. So we've found in our research
但如果它有20%的例外情况，如果我们开始排除这些作为好的解释，我们可能会排除那些实际上非常有用的东西。没错。所以试图寻找一个好的解释的一个危险是，正如你指出的那样，世界并不总是表现良好。有时世界并没有提供一个好的解释。有时事情只是巧合或偶然，或者没有优雅的解释。所以我们在研究中发现
that sometimes that can be a good thing because people persist in trying to find a good explanation and in the course of doing that they might discover important things about the world. But other times it might lead them to perseverate in trying to find a good explanation when there's just none to be had. And if you buy the idea that explanations in some ways provide us with pleasure, there is also potentially a risk here
有时这可能是一件好事，因为人们坚持试图找到一个好的解释，而在这样做的过程中，他们可能会发现关于世界的重要事情。但其他时候，这可能会导致他们在根本没有解释的情况下，执着于试图找到一个好的解释。如果你相信解释在某种程度上给我们提供了快乐，这里也潜在地存在一种风险
because it could be that some explanations, in fact, are more pleasurable than others. In fact, they feel like they fit better. They're more enjoyable to contemplate. And if we're drawn to explanations in part because we derive pleasure from them, it's quite likely that from time to time we're going to draw the conclusion
因为事实可能是，有些解释确实比其他解释更令人愉悦。事实上，它们感觉更契合。它们更令人赏心悦目。如果我们被解释所吸引，部分原因是我们从中获得了快乐，那么很有可能我们时不时会得出结论
that the pleasurable explanation is the right explanation when in fact it's not. I think that's right. So in my own work, I sometimes talk about explanatory virtues, which are properties like simplicity that make an explanation good and that often things that we should be seeking in science and everyday life, but we also fall prey to explanatory vices, characteristics of explanations
认为令人愉悦的解释就是正确的解释，而事实并非如此。我认为那是对的。所以在我的工作中，我有时会谈论解释的美德，它们是像简单性这样的属性，使一个解释变得优秀，并且通常是我们应该在科学和日常生活中寻求的东西，但我们也容易陷入解释的恶习，即解释的特征
that are seductive and that draw us in, but maybe aren't really good guides to how we ought to think about the world. How does this this body of work play out when it comes to things like polarization and partisanship? Well, I think explanation is sort of a funny process and that it can lead to two very diametrically opposed consequences. So, typically, when we try to explain something, we're trying to accommodate it in the context of what we already believe. Part of what's going to make it simple and compelling is that it fits in with the assumptions that we're already working with.
它们具有诱惑力，吸引我们，但可能并不是我们应该如何思考世界的真正好的指南。当涉及到两极分化和党派之争之类的事情时，这套工作是如何发挥作用的呢？嗯，我认为解释是一个有点奇怪的过程，它可能导致两个截然相反的结果。所以，通常当我们试图解释某事时，我们是在试图将其纳入我们已经相信的背景中。使其简单且令人信服的部分原因是它符合我们已经使用的假设。
But sometimes, trying to explain something might lead us to realize an inadequacy in our current theorizing, and so it might be the impetus for us to revise our beliefs. And you sometimes see this in the history of science. So explanation on the one hand can be a way to assimilate everything in the context of what you already believe. And it can also sometimes be a mechanism to spark belief or vision and change. And I think what we see in the case of politics is that overwhelmingly it ends up being a force that allows us to assimilate things in the context of what we already believe. Because often political beliefs are deeply ingrained, tied to people's identities, and so on. I do think that explanation does have the potential to lead us to change our
但有时，试图解释某事可能会导致我们意识到当前理论的不足，因此它可能是我们修正信念的动力。你有时会在科学史上看到这一点。所以解释一方面可以是一种在已经相信的背景下同化一切的方式。它有时也可以成为激发信念、愿景和改变的机制。我认为我们在政治案例中看到的是，绝大多数情况下，它最终成为一种允许我们在已经相信的背景下同化事物的力量。因为政治信仰通常根深蒂固，与人们的身份等等联系在一起。我确实认为解释确实有可能引导我们改变我们的
belief, not just to confirm the beliefs that we already have. But I think the political discourse we see right now makes it difficult for those kinds of conditions to obtain. It's also the case that when we have strong views about something and we see a disconfirming piece of evidence that comes in, in some ways it's easier to sort of find a way to discount the disconfirming piece of evidence than to revise the model that we have built up, especially if that model has been built up over time and with effort, right? This is why it's so hard, not just in politics, but in science as well, to let go of path theories. You've spent 20 years developing a theory. It's incredibly
信念，而不仅仅是确认我们已经拥有的信念。但我认为我们现在看到的政治话语使得这些条件难以实现。同样的情况是，当我们对某事有强烈的看法，并且看到一个反驳的证据出现时，在某种程度上，找到一种方法来打折这个反驳的证据比修正我们建立的模型更容易，特别是如果那个模型是随着时间的推移和努力建立起来的，对吧？这就是为什么不仅在政治上，在科学上也很难放弃旧理论。你花了20年时间发展一个理论。这极其
painful to let that theory go because some new fact has just arisen. Absolutely. Often this is referred to as explaining away, right? So you see it as crap and observation and it's easy to think, oh well, there must have been a mistake with a microscope that day, or somebody must have made a mistake copying down that number. So we find an alternative explanation that doesn't threaten our core beliefs in that case. And I can see this happening all the time in politics. You have a president whom you don't like, and there's nothing that the president can do that can possibly make you think that this was a good decision, because you're filtering everything now through the model that basically
痛苦，因为一些新的事实刚刚出现，就不得不放弃那个理论。绝对是。这通常被称为“解释掉”，对吧？所以你把它看作垃圾和观察，很容易想到，哦，那天显微镜肯定出了问题，或者有人在抄写那个数字时肯定犯了错误。所以我们找到了一个替代的解释，在这种情况下不会威胁到我们的核心信念。我可以看到这种情况在政治中一直发生。你有一个你不喜欢的总统，总统所做的任何事情都不可能让你认为这是一个好的决定，因为你现在正在通过基本上
says this president is an abomination. That's right, and you also see it in the way that we think about social groups and stereotypes. So if you come across an individual who violates your views about a particular stereotype, you could revise the stereotype. But often that's not what people do, often what people do is say, oh, well, this person doesn't fit the stereotype for such and such reason. They come up with an explanation for why that person is an exception. And doing that then allows them to maintain the belief they had about the general group
说这位总统是令人憎恶的模型来过滤一切。没错，你在我们思考社会群体和刻板印象的方式中也能看到这一点。所以如果你遇到一个违反你对特定刻板印象看法的人，你可以修正这个刻板印象。但通常人们不会这样做，人们通常做的是说，哦，好吧，这个人因为这样那样的原因不符合刻板印象。他们为为什么那个人是个例外想出了一个解释。这样做然后允许他们保持他们对一般群体的信念
and to preserve the stereotype. Hmm. You've also cited research about how our drive for explanation and storytelling works in the criminal justice system. Can you talk about that research about how storytelling and explanations shape the practice of justice? Sure, there was a really influential model of juror decision making called the story model that was introduced by Pennington and Hastie. And their idea was that if you think about what a juror is doing, as they have evidence presented to them, as they hear testimony, as they hear the prosecution of the defense and so on, is trying to construct something like a mental model that's a story of what happened.
并保留刻板印象。嗯。你还引用了关于我们对解释和讲故事的驱动力如何在刑事司法系统中发挥作用的研究。你能谈谈关于讲故事和解释如何塑造司法实践的研究吗？当然，有一个非常有影响力的陪审团决策模型，叫做佩宁顿和哈斯蒂提出的故事模型。他们的想法是，如果你考虑陪审员在做什么，当证据呈现给他们时，当他们听到证词时，当他们听到控方辩方等等时，是在试图构建某种像心理模型的东西，即发生的事情的故事。
And the way people decide whether they're going to convict or not is by evaluating which story is better, which does a better job of accounting for all of the evidence. That may sound sort of innocuous, but it leads to some problematic consequences. So one of them is that if you change the order in which people hear testimony such that it makes it easier or harder to construct the story that's consistent with the prosecution, for example, that will affect how likely it is the participants think that that story is the right one. In other words, both the defense and the prosecution think that that story is the right one.
人们决定是否定罪的方式是评估哪个故事更好，哪个故事在解释所有证据方面做得更好。这听起来可能有点无害，但它会导致一些有问题的结果。所以其中之一是，如果你改变人们听到证词的顺序，使得构建与控方一致的故事变得更容易或更难，例如，那将影响参与者认为该故事是正确故事的可能性。换句话说，辩方和控方都认为那个故事是正确的。
In other words, both the defense and the prosecution, hypothetically, are presenting the same facts, but one of them is constructing the story of the facts better than the other one where more likely to believe the side that presents the better story. That's right. And in this case, what makes it a better story is just the fact that it was presented in the right temporal order in which the events unfolded so that it was easier to construct that story in your mind. On September 11, 2016, this was 15 years after the World Trade Center attack. Someone
换句话说，辩方和控方，假设地，都在陈述相同的事实，但其中一方构建事实故事的能力比另一方更好，我们更有可能相信呈现出更好故事的一方。没错。在这种情况下，使它成为一个更好的故事仅仅是因为它以事件展开的正确时间顺序呈现，因此在你的脑海中更容易构建那个故事。2016年9月11日，这是世界贸易中心袭击事件发生15年后。有人
took a photo of the 9-11 memorial tribute in light. Two very powerful blue lights representing the twin towers were beamed into the sky, and at the top, there appeared to be a strange glowing figure. I want to play you a short news clip. Two powerful lights soar into the air as a tribute to lives lost on 9-11. But look closer, there's an image atop the lights. The photo is now a worldwide sensation. Is this a trick of the light? Jesus, an angel, a cross? Beautiful. Amazing. Can you talk a moment, Tanya, about the role that some explanations
拍了一张9-11纪念灯光秀的照片。两道非常强大的蓝色光束代表双子塔射向天空，在顶部，似乎出现了一个奇怪的发光人物。我想给你播放一段简短的新闻片段。两道强大的光束冲向天空，作为对9-11中失去生命的纪念。但仔细看，灯光上方有一个图像。这张照片现在成了全球轰动。这是灯光的把戏吗？耶稣，天使，十字架？美丽。太神奇了。你能谈谈，坦尼娅，一些解释可能扮演的角色吗？
might play in providing us with, in some ways, an emotional defense system, a way of sort of reconciling ourselves to things that might otherwise be very painful to contemplate? reconciling ourselves to things that might otherwise be very painful to contemplate. There are some evidence that when people feel uncertainty or a lack of control in their own lives, one response that they might have is to try to latch on to their ideology or an explanatory framework that gives them a sense of order in the world. And for some people that might be religion, for other people, it might be a sense that the government is a very stable, powerful force that can provide order. It could be the idea that science gives us a very orderly picture of the world. But it does seem like
在某种程度上为我们提供一种情感防御系统，一种让我们与那些否则可能非常痛苦而难以思考的事情达成和解的方式？与那些否则可能非常痛苦而难以思考的事情达成和解。有一些证据表明，当人们感到不确定或生活中缺乏控制感时，他们可能采取的一种反应是试图抓住他们的意识形态或一个给他们世界秩序感的解释框架。对于一些人来说，那可能是宗教，对于其他人，那可能是政府是一个非常稳定、强大的力量，可以提供秩序的感觉。这可能是科学给我们提供了一个非常有秩序的世界图景的想法。但它确实看起来
the idea that there is structure, an order, and regularity is something that we're drawn to in the face of moments that seem anxiety- provoking and to suggest that maybe the world is just random in a very uncomfortable way. I'm thinking about the study that Jennifer Witson and Adam Gylinski did several years ago. They induced a feeling of a lack of control among volunteers and they found that compared to a control group, volunteers who experienced a lack of control showed increased pattern recognition in noise. So in other words, when they were shown like the static on a television screen, for example,
存在结构、秩序和规律的想法是我们面对似乎引起焦虑的时刻时所倾向的，并暗示也许世界只是以一种非常不舒服的方式随机存在。我正在思考詹妮弗·威特森和亚当·吉林斯基几年前做的研究。他们诱导志愿者产生一种缺乏控制感的感觉，他们发现与对照组相比，经历缺乏控制感的志愿者在噪音中表现出更强的模式识别能力。换句话说，当他们被展示像电视屏幕上的静态图像时，例如，
they thought that they could see images in the television screen. Or when they were shown random gyrations in the stock market, they felt like they could detect patterns in what was going on. And Jennifer Wittson and Adam Gylinski thought that there was some connection between these two things, that in the presence
他们认为他们可以在电视屏幕上看到图像。或者当他们被展示股市中的随机波动时，他们觉得他们可以检测到正在发生的事情中的模式。詹妮弗·威特森和亚当·吉林斯基认为这两者之间有一些联系，即在存在
of a feeling of a lack of control, we actually seek to impose control by seeing patterns where none exist. Can you talk about how this phenomenon connected to your work is potentially behind some of the conspiracy theories we see circulating in the world today. When I do, and I will confess this is somewhat speculative, but you might think of conspiracy theories as an error of over-explaining. have the characteristic that they take lots of observations that might all have independent explanations that might sometimes be partially due to chance, and they connect them all to one underlying individual or group that has a particular intention and is carrying out
缺乏控制感的情况下，我们实际上通过在不存在模式的地方看到模式来寻求施加控制。你能谈谈这个与你的工作相关的现象是如何潜在地成为当今世界上流传的一些阴谋论背后的原因吗？当我这样做时，我承认这有些推测性，但你可以把阴谋论看作是一种过度解释的错误。它们具有这样的特征：它们采用了许多可能都有独立解释、有时可能部分归因于偶然的观察结果，并将它们全部连接到一个具有特定意图并正在执行
that intention. And so that's a case where maybe there is no satisfying explanation for why these five independent observations came to be and how they unfolded exactly the way they do, but the conspiracy theorists impose one. And certainly, I think you see that these kinds of beliefs can be heightened in the context of uncertainty, lack of power, and so on. And you know, when you think about the conspiracy theory that the United States government was behind the 9-11 attacks, for example, the complexity of what would be involved in having a conspiracy led that actually work.
该意图的潜在个人或群体身上。所以这是一个可能没有令人满意的解释来解释为什么这五个独立的观察结果会发生以及它们究竟是如何展开的情况，但阴谋论者强加了一个。当然，我认为你可以看到这些类型的信念在不确定性、缺乏权力等背景下可能会加剧。你知道，当你想到美国政府是9-11袭击幕后黑手的阴谋论时，例如，让一个阴谋真正起作用所涉及的复杂性。
I mean, I live in work in Washington. I know that you can't tell anything to a group of three people in Washington and expect it to be kept a secret for very long. Washington is full of leaks. The idea that hundreds of thousands of people across the federal government could have kept this massive secret is just completely implausible. Of course, that's precisely the conspiracy theory that circulated very widely after the 9-11 attacks and was embraced by large numbers of people around the world.
我的意思是，我在华盛顿生活和工作。我知道你不能告诉华盛顿的三个人任何事情，并期望它能保密很长时间。华盛顿到处都是泄密。成千上万的联邦政府人员能够保守这个巨大秘密的想法简直完全不可信。当然，这正是9-11袭击后广泛流传并被世界各地大量人所接受的阴谋论。
I think that's an interesting example because it illustrates a point that we spoke about before that there's many different ways in which you might think that an explanation is simpler, complex. So in one way, that conspiracy theory is extremely complicated because all of the details of how the government's plan would have been carried out and carried out effectively in a way that's consistent with the fact that we didn't have weeks and so on. That's all extremely complicated. But the part that's very simple is that many outcomes are all attributed to one underlying entity,
我认为这是一个有趣的例子，因为它说明了我们之前谈到的一点，即你可能认为解释更简单、更复杂的许多不同方式。所以从某种意义上说，那个阴谋论极其复杂，因为政府计划将如何执行的所有细节，以及以一种与我们没有泄密等事实一致的方式有效执行。那一切都极其复杂。但非常简单的一部分是，许多结果都被归因于一个潜在的实体，
in this case, an organization rather than a single person, with a particular intention. And so in that sense, it might be a relatively simple explanation in that it reduces many observations to something that's sort of a simple root cause, even though the details of how that root cause manifests in what we observed is extremely complicated. We talked earlier in our conversation about the power of explaining and helping us understand things, that it actually could be a mechanism for learning. And you've talked before about how we can utilize this in some ways to combat some of our biases. So, it is the case that we often seek explanations that match our pre-existing views, but how
在这种情况下，是一个组织而不是一个人，具有特定的意图。所以从这个意义上说，它可能是一个相对简单的解释，因为它将许多观察结果简化为某种简单的根本原因，即使该根本原因在我们观察到的事物中表现出来的细节极其复杂。我们在谈话中早些时候谈到了解释的力量以及帮助我们理解事物，它实际上可能是一种学习机制。你之前谈到过我们如何利用这一点在某种程度上对抗我们的一些偏见。所以，确实我们经常寻求符合我们既定观点的解释，但我们如何
can we use explanations to combat this bias, Tonya? I think there's a few ways in which explanation can help us. One way it can help us relates to a previous example. We talked about the case where children will draw the lesson from a story that you should be kind of three-legged dogs, rather than realizing that there's something more general to be learned there. What we found in a study looking at cases like that is that just prompting someone to explain
利用解释来对抗这种偏见，坦尼娅？我认为解释可以帮助我们的方式有几种。它能帮助我们的一种方式与之前的例子有关。我们谈到了孩子们会从故事中得出你应该对三条腿的狗友好的教训，而不是意识到那里有更普遍的东西可以学习的情况。我们在研究这类案例时发现，仅仅提示某人解释
different parts of the story, why the characters acted the way they did, why something was the right or wrong thing to do. That can lead young children to re-represent the story, such that they realize it's not just about a three-legged dog, but maybe more generally a story about social inclusion. So, that's an example of explaining, leading us to change the way we're representing something in a way that helps us appreciate something at a broader level of abstraction.
故事的不同部分，为什么角色表现得那样，为什么某事是正确或错误的事情。这可以引导年幼的孩子重新表述故事，使他们意识到这不仅仅是关于一条三条腿的狗，而是可能更普遍地是一个关于社会包容的故事。所以，这是一个解释引导我们改变我们表述某事的方式的例子，以一种帮助我们在更广泛的抽象层面上欣赏某事的方式。
And it's interesting when it comes to something like fighting conspiracy theories, we really don't practice what you just suggested. You know, we often believe the way to combat a conspiracy theory is to throw evidence against it, but really the more effective approach might well be to ask the person with a conspiracy theory to actually explain it in depth to us. And to have them in some ways discover the gaps in their own beliefs that are
当涉及到像打击阴谋论这样的事情时，这很有趣，我们真的没有实践你刚才建议的内容。你知道，我们经常认为打击阴谋论的方法是向它抛出证据，但实际上更有效的方法很可能是要求有阴谋论的人真正向我们深入解释它。并让他们在某种程度上发现他们自己信念中的差距，这些差距是
surfaced by this illusion of explanatory depth. That's right. In fact, there's some evidence in the political domain that asking people to explain policies, like how a particular tax policy would work, for example, helps them to appreciate that maybe they don't understand it as well as they thought they did. And that can induce a kind of humility or an appreciation that you might not be in the best position
由这种解释深度的错觉所揭示的。没错。事实上，在政治领域有一些证据表明，要求人们解释政策，例如某种税收政策将如何运作，有助于他们意识到也许他们并不像他们想象的那样理解它。这可以诱导一种谦逊或一种欣赏，即你可能并不处于最佳位置
to have a very firm perspective on that political issue and perhaps be more open-minded and willing to revise your beliefs. They speed some work that shows that when we come up with explanations for things, we're more likely to actually believe those explanations. In other words, if I'm in a debating tournament, for example, and I'm randomly assigned to make one case, I'm more likely to believe the case that I'm making. So genuinely, the act of coming up with explanations and arguments prompts me to actually believe what it is that I'm arguing.
对那个政治问题有非常坚定的看法，也许更开放，更愿意修正你的信念。他们加速了一些研究，表明当我们为事物想出解释时，我们更有可能真正相信这些解释。换句话说，如果我在辩论赛中，例如，我被随机分配去陈述一个案例，我更有可能相信我正在陈述的案例。所以真正地，想出解释和论点的行为促使我真正相信我正在争论的内容。
And you and others have talked about the value of essentially, if you want to de-buy us yourself, one thing to do is to try and make arguments in favor of both sides. That the effort of coming up with an argument in favor of both sides, that the effort of coming up with an argument in favor of both sides allows you to see the virtue of different positions that you might not otherwise choose to do. Absolutely. So the strategy you just described is sometimes referred to as consider the opposite. And it sounds very, very simple, but it's also very powerful and very broadly applicable.
你和其他人谈到了本质上的价值，如果你想消除自己的偏见，可以做的一件事是尝试为双方提出论点。为双方提出论点的努力，为双方提出论点的努力，让你看到你可能不会选择做的不同立场的优点。绝对是。所以你刚才描述的策略有时被称为“考虑相反面”。它听起来非常、非常简单，但它也非常强大且应用广泛。
And part of the reason it's so powerful is because it's not something that we tend to do spontaneously. So if you're asked to consider a particular view or coming up with an explanation for a particular observation, you tend not to spontaneously think but how might I be wrong or what might some alternative perspectives be. But doing that can be a very powerful way
它之所以如此强大，部分原因在于它不是我们倾向于自发去做的事情。所以如果你被要求考虑一个特定的观点或为特定的观察结果想出一个解释，你倾向于不会自发地思考，但我可能会如何错误，或者可能有哪些替代观点。但这样做可能是一种非常强大的方式
to avoid some of the kinds of biases that you refer to. I'm wondering if there have been times in your life where you're looking back, you realize that you leap to the wrong conclusion or drew the wrong explanation. Have there been moments like that when you've looked back at and sort of said, uh-oh, I felt prey to the same things that I'm studying? I can think of one example when I was a college student. So it was my birthday and my boyfriend had planned what was supposed to be a nice dinner for me. And on the way to our dinner, he said, oh, you know what?
来避免你提到的某些类型的偏见。我想知道在你生命中是否有过这样的时刻，当你回顾过去时，你意识到你跳到了错误的结论或得出了错误的解释。是否有过这样的时刻，当你回顾过去并说，哦，糟糕，我陷入了和我正在研究的同样的事情？我可以想到一个例子，当我还是大学生的时候。那是我的生日，我的男朋友计划了一顿本应该是为我准备的丰盛晚餐。在去晚餐的路上，他说，哦，你知道吗？
I just need to get these books from the library. Do you mind if we just stop by and pick up these books? Here you take these call numbers so that we're fast. And my immediate temptation was to fit this into a frustrating pattern of having taken second place to immediate work concerns and so on. Right? This was supposed to be my birthday. We shouldn't be doing this errand. And I very shortly discovered I had to revise this assessment because it turns out that my then boyfriend now has been had hidden my birthday presents throughout the library at Stanford University under different
我只需要从图书馆拿这些书。你介意我们顺便去拿这些书吗？你拿着这些索书号，这样我们很快。我立刻的诱惑是将其归入一个令人沮丧的模式，即在即时工作问题等方面排在第二位。对吧？这本应该是我的生日。我们不应该做这个差事。我很快发现我必须修正这个评估，因为事实证明，我当时的男朋友，现在的丈夫，把我的生日礼物藏在斯坦福大学图书馆的不同
call numbers. And so as I was walking around the library trying to get these books, I was discovering the hidden gifts hidden in the library. What a lovely story. And I feel like this tells us something really important because of course the story that we're painting about explanations is not just a story about How we think about politics or how we think about science But it's also about how we think about the people in our lives our colleagues that our partners our children our parents and so often We're drawing these very quick
索书号下。所以当我走在图书馆里试图拿这些书时，我发现了藏在图书馆里的隐藏礼物。多么可爱的故事。我觉得这告诉了我们一些非常重要的事情，因为当然我们正在描绘的关于解释的故事不仅仅是一个关于我们如何思考政治或我们如何思考科学的故事，它也是关于我们如何思考我们生活中的人，我们的同事，我们的伴侣，我们的孩子，我们的父母，我们经常在画这些非常快的
Explanations about why they're doing what they're doing and very often these conclusions are actually wrong and we really need to slow down and ask ourselves how do I know what I think I know. That's right, yeah absolutely. I think asking ourselves how we know what we think we know and thinking about alternative explanations are both very powerful tools for trying to overcome some of our tendencies to leap to conclusions and go with our familiar explanations. Tanya Lombrozo is a psychologist and director of the Concepts and Cognition Lab at Princeton University.
关于他们为什么做他们正在做的事情的解释，而且这些结论往往实际上是错误的，我们真的需要慢下来问自己，我怎么知道我以为我知道的东西。没错，是的，绝对是。我认为问自己我们怎么知道我们以为知道的东西，并思考替代解释，都是试图克服我们跳到结论并使用我们熟悉的解释的倾向的非常有力的工具。坦尼娅·隆布罗佐是普林斯顿大学的心理学家和概念与认知实验室主任。
Tanya, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Bray. Thank you for having me. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Kristen Wong, Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero for this episode is a research paper
坦尼娅，谢谢你今天加入我的“隐藏大脑”。谢谢你的邀请。Hidden Brain由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、劳拉·夸雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、克里斯汀·王、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是Hidden Brain的执行编辑。我们这一集的无名英雄是一篇研究论文
published by Nick Jader and George Lowenstein. It was titled The Underappreciated Drive for Sense Making and was published in the Journal of Economic Behavior and Organization in 2016. I remember reading the paper with much excitement one weekend. I realized I had never given much thought to what lay beneath our drive to make sense of the world. The ideas in that paper helped lead me to Tanya Lombroso's remarkable body of research. For more hidden brain, subscribe to our weekly newsletter
由尼克·贾德和乔治·洛温斯坦发表。它题为《被低估的意义构建驱动力》，于2016年发表在《经济行为与组织杂志》上。我记得那个周末非常兴奋地读了那篇论文。我意识到我从未过多思考过我们理解世界的驱动力背后是什么。那篇论文中的想法帮助我找到了坦尼娅·隆布罗佐卓越的研究成果。更多关于Hidden Brain的内容，请订阅我们的每周通讯
where we explore ideas related to this week's episode and share more about what we are working on, reading and discussing. Sign up at news.hiddenbrain.org. If you like today's show, please consider supporting us. Go to hiddenbrain.org and click on support. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you next week. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在那里我们探索与本周剧集相关的想法，并分享更多关于我们正在做、阅读和讨论的内容。在news.hiddenbrain.org注册。如果你喜欢今天的节目，请考虑支持我们。前往hiddenbrain.org并点击支持。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。下周见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。